and the spirit award winner for best
first feature film goes to
seven days
this is rush and sethi's first
nomination and first win
the film was co-written by sephie and
karen sony who plays the film's league
mark du claus has a cameo voice over as
a character named daddy in the film
and though it's called seven days
filming took eight days
at the start of the covet 19 pandemic
[Applause]
oh thank you thank you on behalf of
russian liz and i we just want to thank
everybody who put their heart into this
film from our cast and crew to our sales
team distributors film independent
members thank you so much
thank you to jeremy mackey the fen twins
maddie uh keep going stephanie kazna our
editor um amanda jones our composer like
you said we had the best cast and crew
we filmed this in september of 2020 when
it was really difficult and we filmed it
in true indie spirit and duplo spirit
duplus brothers have been amazing and we
were really really fortunate and
grateful to be able to come together on
set and make this as a family a film
about connection really quickly justin
williams alex cason jeremy mackey um
edward fiarro uh daniel mccoy and uh
amen cotter jessica lacy and jessica
um and to my brother and my mom and to
current son something
sony and geraldine and geraldine thank
you thank you everybody
[Applause]